[MUSIC PLAYING]
DONNA MALAYERI:
I'm Donna Malayeri.
I'm a product manager
on the Serverless team.
I work on Knative eventing
in App Engine Flex.
So why don't you take turns
introducing yourselves?
MORGAN HALLMON: Sure.
Is this on?
Great.
So I'm Morgan Holman.
I'm also product manager
on the Serverless team.
I work on our event-driven
infrastructure and products.
So when you've used
Cloud Function,
and you've triggered
it off a GCS
bucket, a real-time database
transaction, or a Firestore
collection change, that's
the work I've been doing.
KAROLINA NETOLICKA: Hi, my
name is Karolina Netolicka.
I'm a product manager for
serverless networking.
I manage the networking
features for App Engine,
Cloud Functions, and Cloud Run.
MICHAEL ABD-EL-MALEK: My
name is Michael Abd-El-Malek.
I'm a software engineer working
on serverless infrastructure,
so it's the same infrastructure
behind App Engine
Standard, Cloud Run, and
Google Cloud Functions.
MATTHEW SOLDO: Hi,
my name's Matt Saldo.
I am the product manager
for App Engine Standard,
and I am a mediocre
Ruby developer.
DONNA MALAYERI: All right.
So one of the things
we've realized this week
is that serverless
means different things
to different people.
In fact, some people
have been saying,
you've launched a product,
that's not serverless.
Yes, that's totally serverless.
So we're not going
to answer and debate
what serverless is and
isn't, but instead,
what I'm going to do is ask and
invite each panelist to talk
about why they are personally
excited about serverless.
And I'll go last, so why
don't you start, Morgan?
Why are you excited
about serverless?
MORGAN HALLMON: Sure.
So I'm super excited
about serverless.
I mean, obviously, I'm a
serverless product manager,
so I'm somewhat biased.
But you know, that dev
keynote yesterday was called
Get To The Fun Part, right?
And I think that's what
serverless represents
for a lot of developers.
It is the business
logic, the business value
versus all the mundane--
yet very, very important--
operational things
like patching OSes and
configuring web servers
and horizontal scaling.
We just abstract all
that away for you.
And we see examples of this.
We've got customers
on Cloud Functions,
on Google App Engine that are
serving millions of end users
with ridiculously small
operations teams of, like, one
or two people.
And so that just shows
you how productive,
how lean a developer team
can be when it doesn't have
to think about infrastructure.
And so I'm super excited about
broadening that, so products
like Cloud Run, that lets
you bring many, many more
things to serverless--
so that all developers
can reap those benefits of
serverless architecture.
KAROLINA NETOLICKA:
So one thing that
excites me about serverless is
you only pay for what you use.
And so I'll tell you a story.
I joined the App Engine
team about three years ago,
and so, I've worked on a number
of features for App Engine.
And, typically, when
we're close to releasing
I create a personal test
account with my personal email
because I want to just make sure
to use it like a regular user.
And I test the feature,
and then we ship it.
And so recently, I started
working on VPC connectivity.
And so, I created a
personal test project,
and I created a
couple VMs, so that I
have something to connect to.
And I sent out the link
to a couple other people.
And at the end of the
month, I got a bill,
and it was $250 to
my personal account.
And I said, what is this?
I've never gotten a
bill in three years
that I've worked on App Engine
for testing these things.
And then I realized,
still, serverless is great.
MICHAEL ABD-EL-MALEK: What
I'm really excited about
is just how easy it is
to build applications,
and serverless has got more
powerful over the years, right?
We have a bunch of
limitations, especially
in the earlier
versions of App Engine.
And say, Cloud Functions--
we had a concurrency limit,
and there were a fixed number of
languages that were expanding,
but there's still some
kind of limitations there.
But we're now getting into a
much, much lower limitations
in Cloud Run and
that just makes it
that there's a wider
room of applications
you can develop, while
still getting the benefits
that my colleagues
earlier mentioned,
in terms of not having to think
at all about any operations
aspect.
MATTHEW SOLDO: Yeah, so you
know, it's almost become trite,
but it really is the case
that every business is
becoming a software company.
And I really think for the
majority of businesses,
serverless is the right
solution for them.
Unless you are innovating at
a very low level of compute,
why bother dealing
with servers or OSes.
I was talking to a customer
yesterday, who's on App Engine,
and they are a book
self-publishing business.
They let authors
self-publish their books,
and they have a three-person
development team.
Very, very small, and
they're able to do
that because of serverless
and the productivity
that it provides them.
And enabling
businesses like that
really is what gets me
excited and makes me
psyched to go to
bed today and shop
to work and make it easier
for those kinds of companies.
DONNA MALAYERI: Yeah, for
me it's something similar.
I've worked in the serverless
space for over three years--
not all of it at Google--
and I've worked in programming
languages and developer tools
my entire career.
And the big aha moment for me
about why serverless was great
is when I had a lot of client
developers come up to me
and say, I have never
built an application that
connects to something before.
Not end-to-end.
I was always writing
the client, someone else
was writing the service.
And I have never done
anything on the server before.
And I walked up, and I
used a Functions product,
and now I'm productive.
Now I can build an
end-to-end application.
I can work on the parts I
know, which is the client.
And the server
stuff is so simple
that I can manage
that all myself.
So it really eases
the burden of having
to do something on the server.
It makes it a lot more
accessible for more developers.
And even for developers who
could build a complex server
application, you don't have to.
You get to focus
on the fun stuff,
as they were saying in the
developer keynote yesterday.
All right, so I'm
going to open--
I'm going to ask
some panel questions,
and then we'll get
to Q&A. So we're
going to do about
maybe 15 minutes
of pre-canned
questions, and then
we'll take questions from you.
So Morgan, this week,
we launched Cloud Run.
Can you tell us what it
is, and how is it different
from Cloud Functions?
MORGAN HALLMON: Sure.
So Cloud Run, you've
probably heard about it.
It was in, I think, two or
three keynotes, actually.
DONNA MALAYERI: Actually,
a show of hands--
who has seen Cloud
Run demos this week?
Awesome.
MORGAN HALLMON: For those
of you who haven't, you
know, watch Michael's talk.
Very impressive.
Sp, Cloud Run.
So what it is is a
product that allows
you to run
HTTP-driven containers
in a serverless fashion.
So what does that mean?
It means if you can
build a container,
if you can hit the
HTTP, you can run it
without worrying about
any of the infrastructure.
So all the provisioning
of the infrastructure,
all the configuration,
all the scaling--
Google worries about that.
You worry about your
code and your container.
And so, that probably seems
very interesting but why
is it important?
It's important
because, historically,
one of the biggest barriers to
adoption of services for some
of our other products, like
Google App Engine or Cloud
Functions, has
been that customers
haven't had as much control as
they needed over the runtime.
Now let's be honest, App Engine
and Functions support a ton
of different languages
and runtimes, so many,
many things fit very neatly
into the serverless box.
But if your app didn't--
and the worst case was when
you had one tiny, little thing,
like I need one library that I
just can't use with App Engine
or with Functions-- then
you were completely shut out
of the serverless vision.
And so the great
thing about Cloud Run
is that because you
can bring in container,
you can basically
run anything, right?
So that key barrier has
now been broken down,
and we've broadened
the set of workloads
that are addressable by
serverless which really, really
excites me.
Cloud Functions is a much more
curated and opinionated product
in that we, Google,
provide you with runtime.
Now again, we support
many, many runtime,
many, many languages-- we've
got Java, Go, Python, Node.
So many developers
can use Functions.
It's not a huge limitation.
Obviously, as I said
before, Cloud Run
lifts this limitation.
But if your thing does fit,
if your workload does fit
into a Cloud Functions
runtime, then it's
a much more productive,
much faster way
of developing because you
just worry about what's
between those two curly braces.
You just worry about the
business logic, the application
logic, and you leave
everything else to Google.
So I'd say that's the big
difference between Cloud
Run and Cloud Functions.
I do want to talk about the
Functions Framework, which
we also announced
a couple days ago.
So the Functions
Framework is it's kind
of like the best of both worlds,
in a sense, in that it allows
you to write function
code-- so again,
just worrying about what's
between those two curly braces,
not worrying about
any of the rest.
But however, run it anywhere
and be very, very portable
in that the Functions
Framework is, essentially,
a library or set
of files that you
would put in to your directory
in what you're developing.
And it takes care of all
the configuration that's
needed to build that container
that can then run Cloud Run,
can then run Cloud Run on
GKE, can then run anywhere
that Knative, which is the open
API specification for Cloud
Run, run.
So you can run on any Kubernetes
cluster running Knative.
So it could be on-prem,
it could be on AWS,
it could be on Azure,
wherever you want to run that.
So it's kind of the best of
both worlds, in that you just
focus on the application
logic, yet you
get the portability and
the flexibility of having
a container that runs anywhere.
DONNA MALAYERI: Great.
All right, so, Morgan,
you mentioned that Michael
had a great talk about this.
He did a scale
demo that everybody
is talking about on Twitter--
where you scaled up to, I
think it was, how many nodes?
MICHAEL ABD-EL-MALEK: 10,000.
DONNA MALAYERI: 10,000 nodes
in less than 10 seconds.
So why don't you talk about
how we did this scaling,
and what kind of scale
we're seeing here
in Cloud Run that is really
unparalleled in this industry?
MICHAEL ABD-EL-MALEK: Sure.
So with serverless workflows,
they tend to be bursty.
And we wanted customers to
be able to use our serverless
products and not
have to worry about,
do I need to pre-spin instances?
Do I need to send some
artificial workload
to kind of get more instances
ready for any kind of event
that I know is coming up?
And so we wanted to
really kind of push
the boundaries on
rapid, fast scaling
of instances, based
on customer workloads
that customers
don't have to think
about any capacity or instances,
pre-warming, et cetera.
And the way we've kind of pushed
the boundary in Cloud Run--
and I just want to note that the
same infrastructure powers all
of our three
serverless products,
and so we've kind of enabling
it first in Cloud Run,
but we'll get it soon
in Cloud Functions.
And App Engine's billing model
makes this a bit difficult
to introduce there,
but we're going
to have this in Cloud
Functions as well.
But to Donna's
question, so how do we
scale to 10,000 instances in
a matter of 5, 10 seconds?
The way we do this is when a
request comes to our networking
front ends, the front ends
go through a small set
of application servers
to see if there's
an available instance that
can handle that request
or if these application servers
can start a new instance
to handle their request.
Now, if the application servers
are busy because they already
have too many instances,
the networking front ends
will try an ever-expanding
group of application servers
and start an instance in order
to look for an instance that
has available capacity.
And kind of the key
thing that makes
this work is that all the
different networking front
ends, when we have
thousands of them
in each region in a
decentralized managed manner,
use consistent hashing,
so that they're
going through the same
set of application servers
for a particular service and
revision as the other front
ends without any communication.
So there's no centralized
scheduling or centralized load
balancer that can either
be a bottleneck for scaling
or an availability bottleneck.
And so, as we try bigger and
bigger sets of application
servers to start instances,
that kind of simultaneously
lets us scale quickly but also
avoid too many cold starts.
Because you could-- one
way to do rapid scaling
is to just randomly go to
any application server.
And if you have
thousands of them,
you're going to incur
a lot of cold starts,
more than you need.
And so as we kind of go
an ever-expanding groups,
and as long as
application servers can
respond quickly
and say, hey, I'm
busy go to another
application server,
then we can rapidly scale
in a matter of seconds
to thousands of instances.
DONNA MALAYERI: Right, and
the reason this matters--
and cold start is
the time it takes
when there's nothing running
to actually getting a response,
right?
And so you want customers to
get a response right away,
so you want low cold start.
And before serverless and
before this fast scale-out,
what customers would do--
and in other cloud
vendors I worked in,
they would pre-provision.
They're like, oh, we have
a big sale coming up,
or it's Black Friday.
Let's allocate-- and I'm seeing
some nods in the audience.
You know.
Let's allocate thousands of
VMs in advance so we're ready.
And what happens is you
have to do all this capacity
planning in advance.
You pay for capacity
you're not using.
If you're wrong, if
you've under-provisioned,
now you're really stuck
because you have to wait,
you know, minutes for
new capacity to start up.
That's why the scale-out
is so valuable,
and it's one of those things
that makes serverless actually
useful in practice, when
you have a lot of load
coming to your service.
So I recommend watching the
video for Michael's talk.
It's really fascinating.
So now, we mentioned
the product.
And of course, when a
new product launches,
everyone asks, does this
mean you're not working
on the old products anymore?
And the answer is
no, we are still
working on the old products.
And if you look at our
blog post, you can see,
we have a lot of
new improvements
in Cloud Functions,
as well as App Engine.
Matt is the product
manager for App Engine.
So why don't you tell us
about what we've released
for App Engine this week?
MATTHEW SOLDO:
Yeah, that's right.
So we got a whole
paragraph in the blog post
about our serverless offerings,
but, really, development
is very active on App Engine.
We release a lot of
really fun new things.
So some of you may see--
who is an App Engine user,
is running something
on App Engine?
Good, about a quarter
of the audience.
Great.
So last year, we released
second-generation runtimes
for App Engine.
These are built on the
same infrastructure
that Cloud Run is built on.
Under the covers, they run,
actually, a Docker container,
but you're not exposed to that.
And these unshackled App Engine
from the previous constraints,
where you can run
any language library.
You have open network access
which, believe it or not,
you did not have in the
first edition of App Engine.
And so basically,
you can run any code.
You don't have to write
your code specifically
for App Engine, which
you did in the past.
And so on Tuesday, we
announced several new runtimes.
We have PHP 7.2 in GA,
Python 3.7 in GA, Node 10,
and we also have Ruby in
alpha and Java 11 in alpha.
It didn't make the blog
post, but right about now,
or shortly, Go 1.12 is
also going into beta.
So we have a slew
of new languages.
It's really awesome.
But almost more
importantly-- and Karolina's
going to talk about
more of this--
is VPC Connect for
App Engine, where
you can have an App
Engine app connect
to services that are running
in your Google Cloud VPC.
So yeah, that's right.
That's right.
So the biggest requests we
had on the second-generation
runtimes was the ability
to access a cache
because the second-gen
runtimes do not
use the legacy App
Engine services,
like the Memcache service that
was bundled with App Engine
originally.
So now, it's really easy.
You spin up a VPC connector.
You spin up your Redis
and Cloud Memorystore,
and you've got an awesome cache.
It's plain vanilla Redis.
It works great.
One final thing that
is really exciting
that also didn't make the
blog post, but many of you'll
be hearing about this for the
first time, is this quarter,
we're going to be
doubling the memory
on all second-generation
runtimes at the same price.
So whatever the memory
is on the instances now,
you'll be getting double
that, no change in price.
So really exciting.
It's a great product.
We've designed the
second-generation runtimes
to be future-compatible
with Cloud Run,
so if you are shy about
using a beta product--
no problem.
Develop on App Engine.
And then it's going to
be an incredibly simple,
like almost a one-button
migration, if you ever want
to use Cloud Run in the future.
DONNA MALAYERI: Right.
Yeah, everyone got really
excited about VPC connectors.
This is a really
oft request feature.
We finally made it happen.
We can-- if you want to apply
VPC connectors, go ahead now.
And Karolina is the one
who made this happen.
So why don't you tell us
about the feature we launched,
and why it's important
beyond the case
that Matt just talked about?
KAROLINA NETOLICKA: All right.
So if you use App
Engine, chances
are most customers use more
than one of our Cloud products,
right?
So there are many use cases
where you actually you
want to use App Engine
or Cloud Functions-- so
serverless front end basically.
But it needs to
talk to something
that's running in your VPC.
Perhaps you have a
GCE VM that's running
some off-the-shelf
software that isn't
a good match for
serverless, and you need
to call that from App Engine.
Or perhaps you run--
you wrote some services in GKE
because you needed to use GPUs,
and you need to access
that from Cloud Functions.
Or perhaps you have
an on-premise database
that's connected to your
VPC network via Cloud VPN,
and you want to access that
from your App Engine app
as your storage layer.
So for all these use
cases, in the past,
the options were limited.
You had to basically give the
resource in your VPC network
a public IP address, and
that's how you connected to it.
It's as if it was running--
like there was no
advantage to the fact
that they were both
running in Google Cloud.
So what we have
launched now is we
have a feature called
Serverless VPC Access,
and it's now in beta.
The way you use this
is you create a VPC
connector in the same
region as your app
and in the same VPC as the
things you're trying to access.
And then you redeploy your
app or function, so just
a new version, specifying
the name of the connector.
And from then on,
if in your code,
you call or make a
request to a private IP,
that request is going to
go to the VPC connector.
And, from there,
travel through the VPC
according to however the VPC
network is already set up.
So it's going to respect
all of your firewall rules.
It's going to work
with Cloud VPN,
and it's going to
reach its destination.
So now, you can use Cloud
Memorystore, which, previously,
you actually couldn't
use because Cloud
Memorystore doesn't let
you have public IPs.
And you can use Cloud
Functions and App Engine
with Compute Engine,
GKE, without having
to make those resources public,
so it improves your security.
It also lowers
latency a little bit.
MATTHEW SOLDO: It's super cool.
DONNA MALAYERI: It's
a great feature.
Try it out.
We're all really,
really excited about it.
Unblocks lots of scenarios.
So you know, there's two
versions of Cloud Run.
There's a Cloud Run hosted,
fully-managed version,
and there's a Cloud Run on GKE.
And it's basically the same
developer experience on either,
but if you run in
the GKE version,
you're managing the
Kubernetes cluster yourself.
If you're running
on hosted Cloud Run,
we manage things for you.
So Michael, can you
tell us what do we
manage on behalf of customers?
What worry do we take
away from customers?
MICHAEL ABD-EL-MALEK: Sure.
So I mean, GKE--
we are managing some of
the operations for you,
but you still have to
have a GKE cluster.
And so, with the
hosted Cloud Run,
you don't have to have
a GKE cluster at all.
Or if you have a GKE
cluster for other use cases,
but you don't want to kind
of mix those workloads,
that remains on our
internal hosted platform.
We can scale up faster on our
internal version of Cloud Run.
And so that's zero to
10k kind of scaling demo
that Donna mentioned earlier--
we do not scale that
fast yet on GKE,
so you wouldn't get that
scaling performance.
And so, that's kind
of another thing
that is an advantage of
using the hosted version.
Of course, we are working on
making GKE scalability faster,
both for this use case,
for Cloud Run on GKE,
as well as other customer
use cases on GKE.
But the kind of
technology that's
underlying Cloud Run
hosted has been easier
to make it scale up faster.
You know, there's
no exposed kind
of versions you
have to think about,
in terms of node versions
or GKE versions, master
or node versions.
And so in the Cloud Run
hosted, there really
is no operational aspect
that you have to think about.
All of that stuff is behind.
It runs internally in Google,
so all of the kind of security
operating system image stuff--
all of that is hidden from you,
and we take care of doing that.
If we have to update
our own servers,
that is done
transparently to you.
The request routing-- we'll find
and have an available version.
If there's any server failures,
node failures-- all of that
is hidden from you.
DONNA MALAYERI: All right.
Thank you very much.
Thank you for all
your questions.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]